the movie opens up with a guy named
Frederico Olsen who is seen performing a
ritual with blood and a picture of a
woman minutes later a man named Warren
Lee walks into the scene and cuts off
freder Rico's limbs with a saw this
results in the poor guy's blood being
splashed onto a nearby recliner sofa and
he is seemingly dead in the next scene
we see three people entering a garage
where they find the same sofa with a
note that reads Franchesca the woman
from the picture shown in the beginning
of the movie Franchesca Esa is currently
seen in a club where she works as a
dancer her performance is suddenly
interrupted by two detectives Bob gravy
and Rosanne grape who are assigned to
investigate the case regarding
frederico's death the detectives
interrogate Franchesca and her best
friend Maxi about frto Rico who happens
to be their friend Maxi reveals that
this man was obsessed with Franchesca to
the point that she had a restraining
order against him about 2 years ago
shortly after Franchesca excuses herself
because she is having having some
furniture delivered at her place turns
out that she has purchased the same
recliner sofa being unaware of its dark
history meanwhile the recliner is
mistakenly delivered to an antique
furniture store owner named Jack who is
also Maxi's grandfather however the old
man doesn't recognize the sofa so the
delivery guy calls a number on the Note
in order to find the right address in
the midst of this Jack gets a strange
feeling upon looking at the sofa as he
touches it he experiences a vision of a
woman running through the woods he then
suddenly collapses to the ground but is
somehow revived by the delivery guy
afterwards Maxi drops Franchesca home
where they find Francesca's boyfriend TJ
sitting on the delivered sofa Maxi
doesn't seem to like him and considers
him gay okay but Franchesca simply
brushes her off later while TJ gets the
furniture upstairs Franchesca appears
disturbed by frederico's death as a
result she asks her boyfriend to stay
with her tonight but the latter already
has plans that that night during dinner
Maxi's grandfather can't stop thinking
about his earlier experience he
discusses it with his girlfriend Ashanti
who thinks that he has a psychic gift
like his late Rabbi father believing
that the sofa is possessed by some evil
entity Jack begins to study about the
dbooks a malevolent wandering Spirit
whose name I definitely just said wrong
upon watching a video he learns that one
shouldn't get involved in such evil Acts
or else it will establish a connection
into one's body and mind the video also
warns that it can cause strange health
problems symptoms that are already
evident in Jack in the meantime
Franchesca is showering when she hears a
noise she opens the door only to be
startled by Maxi wearing a scary clown
mask the two then watch a movie together
while also discussing their problems in
life Maxi reveals her decision to shut
down her father's antique store due to
mounting debt she also can't seem to
stop putting on clown masks hearing this
Franchesca advises her to focus on music
as it also aligns with her passion
before leaving Maxi tells her not to
think about freder Rico because what
happened to him is not her fault as she
walks up to her car she notices the sofa
looking at her through the window
looking just like a sofa Dew though it
disappears upon a Second Glance later on
Franchesca has an entranced sexual
experience while reclining on the sofa
at midnight she suddenly wakes up in bed
as if she had a nightmare at the same
time behind the sofa we see a figure of
the same girl that Jack saw in his his
vision the next morning Franchesca wakes
up and finds several candles that lead
her to breakfast on the sofa she assumes
that it was TJ and thanks him for
understanding her need candle sofa Brey
is what all girls need on the other hand
detective gravy reviews the pictures of
the items from the crime scene and
discovers a bunch of voodoo stuff
against Franchesca as a result he
summons her and Maxi for another
interrogation during this session
Franchesca says that a lot of men get
obsessed with her and one of them was
freder she considered him as a friend
but he wanted more from her which is why
she had the restraining order she
believes that her current partner is
immune to her unlike the other guys this
explains why Maxi considers him to be
gay not getting why this matters but you
do you Maxie meanwhile at home TJ is
preparing some meals when the sofa
starts to move on its own it suddenly
slides forward and stabs his legs
leaving him in great pain in a state of
panic he hurriedly calls Franchesca who
then rushes home along with the
detective Ives upon arrival they notice
that the room is filled with smoke and
TJ is lying down in the bathtub bleeding
heavily in the aftermath of this event
TJ who now believes that the sofa is
possessed by evil forces opts to stay at
his mother's place down the street
regardless the sofa doesn't stop
following him later that night TJ hears
tapping on his window and upon
investigation he sees the sofa outside
come on baby kick your feet up freaking
him out he frantically tries to shut the
window but the the sofa blocks it and
breaks into his room he screams for help
but his voice goes unheard as his mother
has her headphones on as a result the
sofa stabs him with its sharpened
upholstery Spring resulting in his
demise the couch is made of memory foam
and it never forgets elsewhere Maxi's
grandfather delves deeper into dbook
research and unearths that it feeds on
The Souls of its victims following this
Jack and his girlfriend perform a ritual
enabling him to relive his vision this
time with more Det detail as he flashes
back to the past he Witnesses a woman
slitting her throat in front of another
woman while a man screams from a
distance as soon as Jack snaps out he
confides everything in his girlfriend
and they come to a conclusion they need
to find the sofa because whoever has it
is in great danger back to Franchesca
she wakes up on her sofa and finds her
underwear on the floor as she goes to
pick it up she sees a reflection of a
man in the door that mysteriously
vanishes she slowly proceeds to check
the door and window window but finds no
one there suddenly she wakes up in her
bed revealing that it was all just her
dream I too have dreams about being
stared at while underwearless just then
she hears a buzzing sound and gets out
of bed to inspect as she looks around
the sofa inexplicably moves scaring her
heart out she hastily makes a call to
Maxi and summons her over sensing the
urgency of the situation Maxi drives to
Franchesca only to find her sitting on
the doorstep seeing her in a disturbed
State Maxi brings her to stay at her
place for the the night while the sofa
watches them as they leave the next
morning Franchesca returns back to her
place and while staring at the sofa she
receives a call from detective gravy
summoning her to the station ASAP as she
prepares to leave she stumbles upon
Maxi's cousin Ralph one of the guys who
is obsessed with Franchesca as usual she
turns him down and heads towards the
station Furious by the rejection Ralph
breaks into her house and begins
installing several cameras all of which
is observed by the mysterious sofa Ralph
also go goes to Franchesca bedroom and
starts fooling around during this time
the sofa slides in come fool around on
me and smashes his head with an iron
killing him on the spot at the police
station Franchesca receives the shocking
news of her boyfriend's demise detective
gravy suspects a connection between this
case and freder Rico he then provides
her with a list of suspects and
Franchesca identifies Ralph as a
potential perpetrator unaware of his
fate gravy also obtains forensic lab
results revealing the involvement of
Warren a guy with a criminal record on
the other hand Jack discovers that the
recliner sofa was delivered to
Franchesca and Ashanti recognizes her as
Maxi's best friend without delay they
urgently summon Maxi home and warn her
about the sofa's evil possession also
emphasizing that her friend is in danger
with this information Maxi goes to
Francesca's place to check on this
mysterious sofa the moment she enters
she Witnesses Ralph's body being dragged
away as she takes a closer look she is
left in shock to notice that Ralph's
pants are down and the sofa is throwing
the body off the balcony she then tries
to retreat quietly but accidentally
makes a noise alerting the sofa to her
presence in a desperate bid for safety
she locks herself in the bathroom but
she inadvertently drops her car keys in
the process as the sofa attempts to
break in Maxi climbs out of the window
only to slip and fall unconscious into a
dumpster despite being at Maxi's Place
Franchesca can still hear a whispering
voice emanating from the kitchen sink
before she can inspect further she is
interrupted by the detectives who are
there to check on her well-being
Franchesca expresses her concern for
Maxi because the latter hasn't answered
her calls for the past 2 hours following
this Franchesca accompanied by the two
detectives heads to her apartment
finding Maxi's keys on the floor they
attempt to contact her again and this
time they hear ringing sounds from below
the detectives proceed to search The
Dumping area only to discover Ralph's
lifeless body at the same time
Franchesca hears the sofa Whispering the
name Valerie which freaks her out in
response she gets into Maxi's car and
drives away afterwards Franchesca
receives a call from Maxi's grandfather
and goes to meet him there the old man
briefs her about the debuk she wonders
about the name Valerie which reminds him
of the couple from the 1800s Gerard and
Valerie who practiced witchcraft they
then delve into history and unearth that
Valerie committed the unthinkable in
front of Marie who happens to be
Francesca's great grandmother according
to Jack Valerie possesses the ability to
elicit obsessive devotion from whoever
crosses her path which is exactly what
Franchesca experiences they also realize
that Franchesca hosts Valerie's spirit
and that she has been fully awakened by
the presence of Gerard who now inhabits
yeah the sofa the old man further
theorizes that frederico's occult magic
opened a portal that allowed Gerard's
Spirit to possess the recliner the two
Spirits are now trying to reunite
although Jack is uncertain how this is
possible since a debuk needs a human
host to do so and freder Rico is
supposedly dead Jack then devises a plan
putting these two evil spirits in a
specially constructed box and burning
them he begins working on it but soon
suffers from a heart attack in the
aftermath Franchesca continues working
on the plan while Ashanti calls medical
help elsewhere detective gravy
interrogates Warren who reveals that
freder Rico asked him to amputate his
legs to fit inside the recliner
simultaneously detective Gra is at
Ralph's house where she finds the camera
footage from Francesca's apartment she
reviews one of the videos and is taken a
to see the sofa moving automatically
knowing that something is wrong with the
sofa she immediately heads towards
Francesca's house after alerting Grave
by this time Franchesca arrives home
with the debuk box and screams at the
sofa to get in the box when it denies
she tries setting the furniture on fire
but it continually blows out each match
flame it's not my birthday not long
after the sofa gets up and slowly walks
towards her but before it can harm her
gravy arrives at the scene and shoots at
it revealing Fredo Rico inside another
shot results in freder Rico's demise
unable to grasp the situation just like
the audience Franchesca rushes to the
bathroom to consume her relaxing pills
suddenly Valerie's Spirit grabs her from
the closet and possesses her body
completely a short while later the
wounded Maxi comes out of the dumpster
and walks upstairs Franchesca quickly
Embraces her and tells her that
everything is over now however we see an
evil smile on her face through the
mirror indicating her evil possession
several days later detective grape
receives a call from the mortuary
informing her that frto Rico's body has
been decomposing for at least 2 weeks
sensing an unresolved issue she quickly
heads to Francesca's apartment on the
other hand Maxi goes through her
grandfather's research and learns that
the debuk can access human carcasses to
store Souls after death if the body is
unusable the Soul can be transferred to
the nearest object until a new host is
found meanwhile gravy is seen at
Francesca's apartment having an
unusually flavored tea probably poisoned
soon after he collapses to the ground
and his body becomes possessed by
Gerard's Spirit detective grape arrives
just in time to witness the completion
of the so transference process after
this the possessed gravy gets up and
kills grape before heading out with
Franchesca now the spirits of Gerard and
Valerie are finally together Maxi
Witnesses all of this from outside and
sneaks into the apartment after their
departure she is on the verge of calling
911 for help when she notices the sofa
moving upon gazing at its button eyes
she sees an image of Francesca falling
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching